can i ask you a question yeah go ahead
amber do you care about being liked for
your personality at all or is just like
your status like would you like a woman
to be attracted to who you are as a
person or does that not matter to you
if you don't reach a certain status
she's not going to give a [ __ ] about
your personality that's the reality i
don't believe that's true
i really don't like i know you're living
in your male experience but i live in my
female experience and i'm okay female
friends and the first thing that
somebody is attracted to is your
personality charm and your charisma the
assets are benefits but they are not the
end-all be-all we need to connect in
order to feel safe and to be attracted
that's that's that's fantastic that you
feel that way but have you ever dated a
woman as a man
i have not okay
yes you're 100 right you need to be
socially calibrated you need to be able
to speak you need to have confidence you
need to be ambitious etc all these
things however a woman isn't going to
even give you the chance
to play the game unless you're of a
certain level and the more attractive
the girl is the more competitive it must
be to be able to even get a shot there's
girls that won't even look your way
unless you have a certain status so they
can have girls but there are other girls
too and i just want to like you you
speak so much in generalizations about
women and the way they behave and that's
fine but there are other girls who are
attracted to personalities the people
who want to create in the world they
want a partner to create and collaborate
remember amber let me ask you and jenny
a question
you got a guy you're dating a guy he's
doing okay he's fine you like him you're
into his personality okay that's that's
exhibit ace you like him you love him
um
there's another guy who's worth way much
more money way much more
social
credibility just bringing a lot more
quote unquote value to the relationship
to the marketplace are you willing to
put up with a little a little bit more
nonsense for that guy
just a little little bit more or is it
like i will not be disrespected i don't
care how much money how much wealth how
much fame you have
i have never dated a rich man i've
always dated creators people who
are at the same status as me and maybe
that will change maybe now that i'm 28
and i am looking for somebody who i can
settle down with maybe those things will
matter more to me i'll give you that i
don't know yet because i haven't at this
moment my main priority is connecting
with somebody i like and have fun with
who respects me if one person put a hand
to me i don't care how much [ __ ]
money you have okay yeah obviously
that's a hand to me or anything
disrespectful jenny you've dated some
you know as you've said successful
successful men guys who got their [ __ ]
together there's a reason you date i
mean kind of to myron's point there's a
reason you
date more successful guys and not just
you know nice guy that you kind of meet
or is there anything like why would you
i guess the question is why date a
successful guy what do they do to you
versus like an unsuccessful guy well
number one i think number one in a
relationship is respect
whatever that entails right if you have
multiple women as long as your women
know i think that's fine yeah me too
you're good with that yeah i am too so
you're both good with myron having
multiple absolutely if that's what he
wants and his women know i think there's
no foul play right 100 in agreement yeah
because everybody's listen there's so
many there's so many things in this
world he's just he he's open about it
yeah so i think i think that's admirable
i just think sometimes maybe his
approach with women like i just met him
and like he i don't know
like certain gestures he makes is very
like oh my god it's not scary he's a
manly dude it's not scary that's fine he
sits very high in his masculine energy
but i do feel like one day a woman will
come and really
help bring out a side of you that will
do you think
you